you're such like a great advocate for
women and I love how you you know I've
done things like posted on Instagram
with no makeup and you're just about
like empowerment so what some people are
talking about this season is like the
me2 and times up movement 7 yeah huge
yeah and the bachelor is such a heavily
female audience yeah do you think the
show needs to adjust update yes tell me
I know this sounds so weird and terrible
to say but I'm kind of like I think it's
time for the robot to end all together
yeah why only because of the time we're
living in and I'm like that whole thing
when I was against Britt to be the
Bachelorette I'm like ah two women being
pitted against each other no and then I
think what I'm like wait there's usually
25 women against each other too and it
just see I don't know I'm I shouldn't
say I wish the bachelor would end
because I still enjoy watching it yeah
but it's just it's a weird time to be
watching this still like I know on my
season the guys wrestled and I didn't
have control over that but watching the
women wrestle I know it was supposed to
have like a different tone with the glow
girls or whatever cuz their show is all
about empowerment but this came across
is like it was like kind of soft porn
mhm do you think there are any changes
that could be made or do you think like
go out on a high note and it's time I
don't think they'll ever ends because
people will always watch the show so
maybe just some adjustments I just don't
know what those would be
[Music]